your girlfriend is not your boyfriend
don't treat them the same if you want to
talk about how ugly the bridesmaid's
dresses were at Marcy's wedding call
your friend Lydia don't call your
boyfriend about it cuz then you come
home and you're like can you believe
what happened at work she was wearing
this blouse and the guy's just like you
know what I mean you don't listen to me
how come you're not paying attention you
don't want to hear me talk it's like
you're boring you're boring dude call
your girlfriend to me it's always a big
red flag when girls don't have
girlfriends cuz that means you're going
to have to hear all the boring so like
girls know what to take to your
girlfriends and know what to take your
boyfriend I think that's a really
important thing that a lot of girls
don't do they expect their boyfriend to
be their girlfriend you're not going to
come to Nordstrom with me and hold my
purse while I change that's not my guy
don't make your guy do sh like that I
just think that like little things like
that I think make a really big
difference and if you are doing that
chances are you might not respect the
person and that's not the person for you
and I think people really forget about
respect it's like I'm attracted to him
and he's smart and he has this but do
you respect him